bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn und
den präsident des robert koch instituts
lothar wieler
da wir wieder live übertragen werden
noch mal ein paar worte zu unserer
institution die bundespressekonferenz
ist regierungsunabhängig ist und bleibt
sie wir organisieren hier
pressekonferenzen unsere mitglieder und
die mitglieder des vereins der
ausländischen presse können hier fragen
stellen bekommen diese auch beantwortet
so ist auch heute wir begrenzen die
pressekonferenz auf eine stunde und
jeder von ihnen hat eine frage mit der
möglichkeit einer nachfrage wenn es die
zeit die kapazitäten zu lassen zweiter
dem frage bedarf gibt nämlich sie wieder
mit auf die liste wir sprechen wie immer
bei diesen freitäglichen
pressekonferenzen über die aktuelle
pandemie lage und beginn waren sparen er
liebe frau wolff meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren mit der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gestern ist
klar deutschland nimmt die lage ernst
bund und länder stemmen sich gemeinsam
gegen die vierte wette unserem ahnung
haben geholfen diese entscheidung kam
spät für viele leider zu spät aber
immerhin wurden sie nun getroffen jetzt
geht es darum die vorgaben umzusetzen
sie zu kontrollieren und sie auch so
schwer es manch einem in seinem alltag
fällt zu akzeptieren
es gab ja immer wieder auch die
diskussion ob der begriff der pandemie
der ungeimpften der richtige ist nun
natürlich ist es richtig dass auch
geimpfte teil desinfektions geschehens
sind zumal bei dieser instanz
und das ist ja in wahrheit auch teil
unseres problems in dieser vierten welle
die erkenntnis die noch relativ neue
erkenntnis dass auch geimpfte nach
einigen monaten wieder stärker
infektionsgeschehen teilnehmen sich
anstecken können und andere anstecken
aber wahr ist und bleibt auch die
inzidenz der ungeimpften liegt in allen
altersgruppen deutlich höher als die
inzidenz der geimpften die zahl der
ungeimpften coop 19 patienten auf den
intensivstationen ist auch relativ zu
ihrem anteil an der bevölkerung
um ein vielfaches höher als die der
geimpften
wären alle erwachsenen deutschen geimpft
steckten wir nicht in dieser schwierigen
lage das ist einfach die wahrheit und
daher ist es so wichtig dass die
gestrigen beschlüsse das auch so klar
adressieren
neben anderen maßnahmen mit einem
konsequenten zweig und zweige plus und
auch mit kontakt beschränkung und
einschränkungen insbesondere auch für
ungeimpfte person
wir hätten viel früher diese konsequenz
im umgang mit ungeimpften bürgerinnen
und bürgern an den tag legen müssen
wenn sie treffen ihre entscheidung sich
nicht impfen zu lassen eben nicht nur
mit folgen für sich selbst sondern in
dieser pandemie immer auch mit folgen
für alle anderen das haben die letzten
wochen schmerzhaft gezeigt
jeder und jede der die immer noch hadert
sollte wahrnehmen wie die lage ist über
ein prozent der deutschen sind aktuell
akut infiziert
die luftwaffe verlegt aktuell viele
patienten pro woche quer durch die
republik mich beschäftigen diese bilder
jedenfalls sehr
in manchen bundesländern werden
zusätzliche möglichkeiten geschaffen um
die vielzahl von verstorbenen einäschern
zu können
und die intensivstation füllen sich
weiter selbst dann wenn die beschlüsse
von gestern ab morgen schon volle
wirkung zeigten ein teil der infizierten
von gestern von vorgestern von heute
wird sich sicher nächste oder
übernächste woche auf den co- witt 19
intensivstationen wiederfinden
deutschland wird die zahl von über 5.000
19 patienten auf den intensivstationen
deutlich noch in den nächsten tagen
wochen übersteigen die lage auf den
intensivstationen wird also wenn die
maßnahmen greifen
rund um weihnachten ihren traurigen
höhepunkt erreichen die enorme belastung
der ärztinnen und ärzte der pflegekräfte
bleibt also weiter enorm und wächst auch
weiter das sollten wir das dürfen wir
nicht vergessen
deswegen meine bitte an jeden einzelnen
nehmen sie die auflagen ernst befolgen
sie auch in ihrem privaten alltag
reduzieren sie kontakte so weit es geht
helfen sie mit weiteres leid zu
verhindern
es geht nicht darum jetzt jede regel
auch auszureizen sondern im zweifel eben
sich selbst dabei zu prüfen im alltag
und das machen viele gott sei dank ja
auch auf dass dieses treffen dieser
kontakt jetzt so sein muss es geht jetzt
darum die vierte welle gemeinsam zu
brechen die betroffenen und diejenigen
die sich um sie kümmern die pflegekräfte
die ärztinnen und ärzte werden es ihnen
danken
zu einem zweiten thema würde ich kurz
auch noch etwas sagen wir erleben gerade
in deutschland wie die impfkampagne
wieder enorm an fahrt gewinnt allein in
den letzten zwei tagen wurden zwei
prozent der deutschen gemeistert haben
ihre auffrischimpfung erhalten
erstmals gab es wieder über eine million
impfung an einem tag es war das letzte
mal am siebten juli der fall über zwei
millionen impfungen in zwei tagen wir
kommen also schritt für schritt zurück
zu den rekordzahlen aus dem frühjahr und
dem frühsommer
stand heute morgen gab es 12,2 millionen
auffrischimpfungen in deutschland und um
die zahl auch nochmal einzuordnen wir
haben 55 millionen zweifach geben der
erwachsene nur für diese ist ja der
booster die auffrischimpfung empfohlen
von diesen 55 millionen geimpften
erwachsenen haben also über 12 millionen
die auffrischimpfung bereits erhalten
von diesen 55 millionen geimpften
erwachsenen werden etwa 30 millionen die
sechsmonatsfrist die wir als richtschnur
haben für die auffrischimpfung erreichen
diese bis zum jahreswechsel auch alle zu
boostern ihnen eine auffrischimpfung zu
ermöglichen ist auch möglich und unser
ziel
übrigens auch wichtig jeder dritte über
60-jährige geimpfte ist bereits auch mit
einer auffrischimpfung zusätzlich
geschützt
booster in stoff jedenfalls ist genug
vorhanden und ab kommender woche ist
eine ausreichende zahl an impfdosen auch
für das gestern gesteckte ziel 30
millionen impfungen zu erreichen quasi
schon ausgeliefert an die impfenden
stellen
olaf scholz gestern in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz deutlich
gemacht dass die 30 millionen impfungen
gezählt werden sollen ab dem 18 11 der
letzten ministerpräsidentenkonferenz als
es die beschlüsse zur auffrischimpfung
gab
seit diesem 18 11 wurden bereits zehn
millionen menschen geimpft wenn jetzt
alle impfdosen genutzt werden die bis
einschliesslich anfang kommender woche
ausgeliefert sind sind diese 30
millionen impfdosen schon an die
impfenden stellen ausgeliefert zehn
millionen sind bereits 15 millionen sind
schon ausgeliefert zehn millionen werden
nächste woche ausgeliefert so dass
jedenfalls von den lieferungen der
impfdosen her dieses ziel der nächste
woche schon erreicht werden kann wichtig
ist jetzt dass verhelfen und es werden
ja woche für woche bis zum jahresende
auch weitere impfdosen folgen all diese
impfdosen die ausgeliefert werden auch
zu verkämpfen das wäre ein großer erfolg
und es wäre das ergebnis einer großen
kraftanstrengung
mein dank gilt daher allen ärztinnen und
ärzten allen helferinnen und helfern vor
ort die mit viel flexibilität die
strukturen dafür wieder auf und ausbauen
die menschen überzeugen und auch
überstunden viele überstunden leisten
mein dank gilt den impfstoffherstellern
die unsere booster kampagne auch durch
zusätzliche lieferungen vorgezogene die
führung insbesondere möglich machen und
mein dank gilt auch den kolleginnen und
kollegen im ministerium bei der
bundeswehr den großhändlern und den
apothekern die diese kampagne logistisch
generalstabsmäßig organisieren unmöglich
machen durch unsere gemeinsame
kraftanstrengung ist es gelungen in
kürzester zeit die impfkampagne wieder
zum leben zu erwecken
so werden wir auch die zahl will ich
noch nennen von mitteln und bis mitte
dezember in diesen vier wochen
nach aktueller planung 18 millionen
dosen biontech und fast 25 millionen
booster dosen moderner an die impfenden
stellen ausliefern mit all diesen zahlen
die sie auch auf unserer homepage finden
will ich eines deutlich machen das
erreichen der gesteckten ziele scheitert
jedenfalls nicht am impfstoff es ist für
die ziele der nächsten vier wochen genug
uster impfstoff vorhanden
wenn wir all diese impfdosen auch für
impfen dann machten wir uns selbst das
größte weihnachtsgeschenk
denn trotz oder auch wegen der neuen
virus variante bleibt impfen und postern
das beste gegen diese pandemie deswegen
machen sie mit lassen sie sich impfen
schützen sie sich und ihre lieben so
können wir diese vierte welle recht
morgen meine damen und herren die
bundesweite sieben tage in tendenz ist
auf einem sehr hohen plateau und es
liegt immer noch ein weiter weg vor uns
die fallzahlen sind nach wie vor viel zu
hoch und wir sollten bei der
interpretation dieses faktors auch
wirklich vorsichtig sein in einigen
bundesländern sehen wir vermutlich
tatsächlich erste folge der verschärften
maßnahmen in einigen anderen regionen
könnte diese plateau bildung aber bei
den hohen fallzahlen zurzeit auch darauf
zurückzuführen sein dass ganz einfach
die kapazitäten erschöpft sind das
infektion nicht mehr so gut erfasst
werden können weil labore und
gesundheitsämter einfach nicht mehr
hinterherkommen mit testen und der
bearbeitung von meldungen es ist also
viel zu früh um ihr eine trendumkehr
auszulesen geschweige denn auf schärfere
maßnahmen zu verzichten im gegenteil
im moment gibt es in deutschland
geschätzt und
926000 aktive fälle das heißt etwas mehr
als ein prozent
der gesamten bevölkerung ist zur zeit
infiziert und wir gehen von einer
untererfassung von etwa faktor zwei bis
drei aus
rund
4800 kurve patienten liegen aktuell auf
intensivstationen die belastung wird
wird in den nächsten wochen ja zu nehmen
durch die weiter nachlaufende hohe zahl
an neuen patienten die auf
intensivstationen kommen unweigerlich
wie erwartet steigen leider auch die
todesfälle deutlich an dem
robert-koch-institut werden an einzelnen
tagen schon um die 400 todesfällen lage
beenden und in dieser notlage hinein
platzt jetzt noch die neue variante
omikron
wir können nikon noch nicht genau
einschätzen aber klar ist dass auch
nikon in deutschland angekommen ist und
nach allem was wir mit stand heute
wissen könnte micon auch noch
ansteckender sein und auch geimpfte und
genesene leichter infizieren das rk ii
beobachtet annika natürlich intensiv
zusammen mit vielen kollegen im ausland
und im inland und sobald neue
erkenntnisse kommen werden wir die
natürlich auch informieren
wir sollten uns alle darauf einstellen
dass omikron in noch kürzerer zeit zu
noch mehr fällen führen könnte als delta
und das in einer situation in der das
gesundheitssystem bereits an vielen
stellen überlastet ist deshalb müssen
alle gestern entschiedenen maßnahmen
auch flächendeckend umgesetzt werden um
infektionen durch die älter und nikon zu
verhindern und um die fallzahlen
herunterzubringen dazu in aller erster
linie die reduktion von kontakten wir
haben keine zeit zu verlieren keinen
einzigen tag nur wenn wir die fallzahlen
herunterbringen können wir die kliniken
entlassen in vielen krankenhäusern ist
die medizinische versorgung jetzt
bereits eingeschränkt und ich möchte
noch einmal klar machen was das bedeuten
kann erstens für die kogit patienten die
zum teil schon verlegt werden müssen
sollte die verlegung sind eine enorme
belastung und können die heilungschancen
beeinträchtigen zweitens für alle
anderen wenn die kliniken am limit sind
wirkt sich das zuallererst auf die
vermeintlich leichten eingriff aus ich
sage bewusst vermeintlich denn auch eine
hüft-op ist in der regel medizinisch
indiziert und wenn sie nicht stattfinden
kann verlängert das eben auch das leid
der betroffenen
etwas später wenn die engpässe dann aber
auch bei komplexeren und
schwerwiegenderen eingriffen bemerkbar
zum beispiel bei krebspatienten darüber
habe ich auch vor ein paar tagen mit dem
vorstandsvorsitzenden des deutschen
krebsforschungszentrum professor baumann
gesprochen um eine krebserkrankung
heilen zu können muss sie rechtzeitig
erkannt werden die moderne krebsmedizin
ist sehr komplex sie wird über einen
längeren zeitraum mit verschiedenen
methoden durchgeführt zb
röntgendiagnostik
probeentnahme operation verschiedene
therapien
wenn ich die diagnose verzögert oder die
behandlung nicht optimal durchgeführt
wird sind die heilungschancen
natürlich geringer wenn zum beispiel
kein intensiv bett zur verfügung steht
kann auch nicht operiert werden schon
jetzt finden laut taskforce krebs und
corona mindestens fünf prozent weniger
tumor operation statt es gibt
internationale auswertung die zeigen wie
sich das sterberisiko bei einigen
krebsarten erhöht wenn sich eine
operation nur um vier wochen verzögert
das kann an einer internationalen
übersichtsarbeit pro 1000 wurst
krebspatientinnen zb zu mehr als zehn
also zu zehn mehr todesfälle also weil
ein bei 1000 brustkrebspatientinnen
krebs führt aber oft erst viele monate
oder später zum tod das bedeutet es eine
benachteiligung von krebspatienten wenn
dieser akuten pandemie eben auch leicht
übersehen werden kann
also jeder und jeder von uns könnte
plötzlich betroffen seien jede und jeder
von uns kann und muss dazu beitragen
infektion zu verhindern überall im
privaten bereich im beruflichen erreicht
in der schule im altenheim deshalb noch
mal wirklich der ganz klarer verlassen
sich impfen achten sie darauf dass ihr
impfschutz vollständig ist und lassen
sie sich eine auffrischungsimpfung geben
und bitte reduzieren sie ihre kontakte
auch ein minimum halten sich im alltag
über an die asl regeln also abstand
halten hygieneregeln
alltags entschuldigend medizinische
masten tagen oder ffp zwei masten tagen
lüften auch bei 3g und 2g
veranstaltungen die maske bleib bitte
auf wir brauchen eine hohe impfquote und
eine niedrige inzidenz um uns selbst und
die einrichtung des gesundheitswesens
vor cupid 19 zu schützen und bitte wenn
sie bereits krank sind oder wenn es
ihnen nicht gut geht oder und sie etwas
entdecken dass ihnen sorge bereitet
suchen sie bitte auch in der pandemie
ihre ärztin ihren arzt aufnehmen sie vor
allem auch
früherkennungsuntersuchung war und ich
bin sehr dankbar dafür dass sich viele
menschen in unserem land so
verantwortungsbewusst verhalten und
damit sich selbst und ihre mitmenschen
schützen oder dass sie bis zur
erschöpfung daran arbeiten diese
situation zu bewältigen in kliniken in
arztpraxis in laboren im öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst und an diversen
anderen stellen wie auch im
robert-koch-institut
vielen lang bekommen zu ihren fragen ich
würde gerne mit den fragen die speziell
das thema dieser pressekonferenz
beginnen sollte betreffen mit diesen
fragen beginnen wir sollte es darüber
hinaus weitere fragen geben setzen wir
die am ende geben sie mir dazu einfach
einen kurzen hinweis ich beginne im saal
mit herrn trinke ich
hätte ganz gerne an einen punkt an
geknüpften er wieder zu anfang seiner
ausführungen erwähnt hatte nämlich die
unter fassungen die verlässlichkeit der
daten deswegen hätte ich ganz gerne
ersparen und er wieder von ihnen gewusst
was man dagegen tun kann und
wie sie die zahlen konkreter beurteilen
die jeden tag von berlin gemeldet werden
also müssen wir jetzt diesen faktor zwei
bis drei da oben drauf rechnen und was
kann man tun damit die gesundheitsämter
wieder in der lage sind die zahlen
verlässlich zu melden dann kann also
zuerst einmal dass es auch eine gewisse
unter erfassung von infektionen gibt ist
ja seit beginn der pandemie so weil
insbesondere natürlich diejenigen geben
zweifel gar nicht merken dass sie
infiziert sind muss sich möglicherweise
dann auch nicht testen lassen nicht
entdeckt werden was ist im moment
schwieriger macht sind zwei facetten
zwei gesichtspunkte das eine ist die
situation in den laboren wenn es um die
pcr test umgeht die jedenfalls sind zum
einen sehr stark am limit übrigens nicht
weil die testkits oder ausrüstung nicht
da wäre sondern weil auch dort natürlich
dass begrenzende momentum personal und
personal verfügbarkeit ist wir haben
jetzt wieder so viel pcr tests in jeder
woche wie auch sonst in den höchst
phasen der pandemie mit gleichzeitig
einem sehr sehr hohen positiv anteil
also der in hoher zahl der testung in
den pcr labor ist positiv so hoch wie
selten in den letzten 18 monaten und das
deutet darauf hin dass es eine unter
erfassung gibt und zum zweiten ist die
situation in den gesundheitsämtern eine
an vielen stellen insbesondere in den
landkreisen in den städten mit sehr oben
infektionsgeschehen wo die meldungen
dann nicht immer tag gleich auch in die
in den systemen erfasst werden erfasst
werden können weil möglicherweise
anderes gerade noch dringlicher ist und
das sehen wir ja an den nachmeldungen
die wir haben
auch beim robert-koch-institut dass das
dann in dem moment wo möglicherweise
dann die inzidenz segen tun ein stück
entlastung eintritt diese nachmeldungen
dann auch erfolgen und im nachhinein die
zahlen ja dann noch erhöhen was kann man
am besten dagegen tun die
infektionszahlen senken das beste was
wir tun können damit wir ein gutes
lagebild wieder haben können miteinander
schlicht und ergreifend infektionszahlen
runterbringen diese bälle brechen so
dass alle auch in ihrem alltag im
gesundheitswesen die dinge die anstehen
gut bewältigen können und da kann jeder
von uns mithelfen
eine andere möglichkeit wäre das
leuchtet natürlich ein mit den
irgendeinen infektionszahlen andere
möglichkeit die gesundheitsämter wieder
stärker mit personal auszustatten auch
das hat man ja in der zweiten welle dann
ist das eine maßnahme die dringend
angegangen werden müsste oder sehen sie
da gar keine möglichkeit natürlich herr
rinke wird und soll und muss auch das
personal verstärkt werden ich meine die
bundeswehr steht wieder auch mit
unterstützung mit den helfenden händen
das ja auch richtigerweise heißt und
soja auch empfunden wird den
gesundheitsämtern zur seite wir tun das
zum teil mit programmen des bundes in
den einrichtungen die behörden vor ort
ziehen das personal im gesundheitsamt
zusammen aber eines bleibt ihm auch war
in regionen mit instanzen von
800.000 1500 neuinfektionen pro
hunderttausende den letzten sieben tagen
ist das eben auch eine größenordnung die
dann auch mit zusätzlichem personal
kurzfristig jedenfalls kaum noch
aufzufangen ist dann beginnen die
gesundheitsämter ist ja auch eine
empfehlung des rk ii eine sinnvolle auch
bei der kontaktperson nachverfolgung vor
allem sich auf die bereiche zu
konzentrieren wo es um wohl der rambla
personen geht um pflegeeinrichtungen zum
beispiel oder um größere veranstaltung
also es gibt ja auch empfehlungen und
maßnahmen auch schon seit längerem wie
in einer solchen auch belastenden
überlasteten situationen in einem
gesundheitsamt an kontaktpersonen
nachverfolgung ist stehen soll in aller
regel auch dann passiert aber das sind
in größenordnungen die wir regional
haben in deutschland da geht es vor
allem darum diese zahlen runter zu
bringen
ich sehe die frage des kollegen heller
digitalen damit auch beantwortet er
fragte auch zu dem fehler faktor das
hatten wir dann bin ich im sommer
hinkriegen
am meniskus sparen in der ersten und
zweiten reihe waren ja vor allen dingen
die pflegeheime besonders hart betroffen
vor dem hintergrund des nachlassenden
impfschutzes jetzt wie gut sehen sie die
pflegeheime jetzt in der vierten welle
geschützt und
wo sehen sie die verantwortung dafür
dass es jetzt doch auch immer wieder zu
mehr zu tödlichen ausbrüchen in
pflegeheimen kommt also zuerst einmal
haben wir sehr bewusst schon im august
vereinbar zwischen bund und ländern die
auf riskante auch in den
pflegeeinrichtungen zu beginnen viele
länder leider nicht alle aber viele
haben auch unmittelbar im august
begonnen mit mobilen teams dann wieder
in die einrichtung auch zu gehen das
impfangebot zu machen stand heute aus
dem was uns die länder zurück melden ist
in nahezu allen pflegeeinrichtungen
dieses angebot auch gemacht worden und
viele der dort lebenden bewohnerinnen
und bewohner haben ist auch angenommen
und sich zusätzlich zu schützen ist
schon ein erster sehr sehr wichtiger
punkt das zweite ist dass regelmäßige
testen auch von geimpften genesenen
personal und besucherinnen und besuchern
um den eintrag in die einrichtung ebenso
weit es geht zu reduzieren zu minimieren
auch als zusätzlichen schutz war
sozusagen das ist ja neben den
landesverordnung die es gegeben hat
mittlerweile auch bundes gesetzlich
geregelt und das kann ich nur begrüßen
wenn
sie dir zu ergänzen
eine nachfrage
für das ihrer ansicht nach auch zur
aufgabe des pflege beauftragten sich ein
bild über die lage in den pflegeheimen
zu machen und zum beispiel über den
stand des fußballs
aus meiner sicht und meiner wahrnehmung
macht sich der pflege beauftragte
täglich ein bild über die lage in den
einrichtungen auch durch persönliche zum
einen durch sozusagen persönliche
gespräche gesprächsrunde in dieser zeit
natürlich vor allem digital aber eben
auch durch seine tägliche arbeit
dann nämlich eine digitale frage dazu
gutes kollegen reuter aus dem
ard-hauptstadtstudio zur allgemeinen
impfpflicht beziehungsweise nämlich
gleich zwei zusammen die erste halten
sie eine allgemeine impfpflicht auch für
menschen unter 18 jahren für sinnvoll
und wenn ja ab welchem alter und der
kollege jordaans von ip fragt wie soll
die geplante impfpflicht effektiv
durchgesetzt werden geht das ohne ein
zentrales register aller personen in
deutschland mit vermerk zum impfstatus
nun sie kennen meine grundsätzlich sehr
skeptische haltung was eine allgemeine
impfpflicht angeht habe in dieser frage
auch mein wort gegeben das wird auch
mein abstimmungsverhalten bestimmen und
insofern ist die frage der durchsetzung
der umsetzung dann auch vor allem an
diejenigen zu richten die den
entsprechenden gesetzentwurf erarbeiten
und einbringen ich meine dass diese
frage der allgemeine impfpflicht
ich bin mir bei 2g lockdown für
ungeimpfte kontakt beschränkungen die
frage wie wir diesen unterschied den
games und nicht geimpft sein macht auch
tatsächlich durch regeln zum ausdruck
bringen sehr sehr klar ich bin auch in
der aus- und ansprache sehr sehr klar
das dürfte wenige bundespolitisch aktive
geben die sich so vielen
diskussionsrunden gestellt haben auch
mit menschen die sich nicht impfen
lassen wollen um sie zu überzeugen aber
auch um sie zu verstehen
insofern bin ich in dem ziel sehr sehr
klar
aber die frage wie das um und
durchgesetzt wird und für wen das ist
tatsächlich eine frage die ich bitte an
diejenigen zu richten die den
gesetzentwurf erarbeiten die frage der
impfpflicht unter
unter 18
auch das ist am ende an diejenigen zu
richten die entsprechend an einem
gesetzentwurf arbeiten
meine wahrnehmung ist dass eine
verpflichtende impfung für unter
18-jährige
die debatte er
mit zusätzlichen
emotionen aspekten naturgemäß noch
versieht
angesprochen
ja also das klima im pflicht muss muss
sehr sehr sorgsam kommuniziert und
überlegt werden und da gibt es ganz
viele fragen und werden sich viele mit
sicherheit auch viele wissenschaftliche
kollegen drüber unterhalten
welches alter sie wird eine impfpflicht
vollzogen wie gehen wir damit um dass
impfungen eben keinen hundertprozentigen
schutz bringen sondern eventuell noch
einmal nachgerüstet werden müssen das
sind eine reihe von fragen die allen
klar sein müssen die muss man vorher in
einem guten maße kommunizieren die
limitationen
der impfpflicht muss man im kopf haben
also ich denke dass da braucht wirklich
eine sehr intensive wartung die pros und
cons herauszuarbeiten und solange diese
debatte nicht wirklich von den menschen
geführt ist die dann auch nachher
übernimmt oder oder also zumindest mit
den menschen die nach über die impfung
entscheiden da muss noch einiges
geschehen ich denke das ist ein das ist
wirklich nicht so trivial aber ich habe
einfach nur die bitte an diejenigen die
die sich damit befassen dass sie
wirklich alle diese pros und cons die
abwägungen
moralischen die ethischen die
gesundheitliche neben treffen und ich
glaube da da muss das land noch sehr
viel diskutieren das ist ja nichts neues
also es gibt ja schon aber an den
anderen ländern im pflichten das ist ja
nun kein neues phänomen
darüber gab es schon vor vielen
jahrzehnten
diskussionen da ist viel gelernt aber
wie gesagt aus meiner sicht muss man das
alles abwägen und ich wünsche mir dass
dort eine fundierte diskussion
stattfindet und dann auch eben eine
wirkliche informierte entscheide im
parlament denn wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe soll das ja eine
gewissensfrage sein was ich auch sowieso
meine ich wunder mich sowieso immer über
die fraktionszwängen bei abstimmungen
aber auf jeden fall ist bei ihm pflicht
eine gewissensfrage ist wichtig da
müssen sich die parlamentarier gut
informieren und auseinandersetzt und
dann kommt doch das richtige ergebnis
raus denn eins ist klar das will ich
noch mal sagen
also ohne dass alle menschen einen
immunschutz haben wenn wir eben es sehr
sehr schwer haben diese pandemie zu
einem stillstand zu
sparen sind für die zeit bis jahresende
zusätzliche impfdosen geordert worden
ich das richtig verstanden habe geht das
aber zum teil durch vorgriff kontingente
mindestens des ersten quartals im
nächsten jahr wie ist sichergestellt
oder wie kann sichergestellt werden und
lässt mich dann eine lücke in der
versorgung eintritt und zuerst einmal
ersten ist es so dass tatsächlich
lieferungen vorgezogen werden nicht
zusätzlich bestellt wurde lieferungen
vorgezogen aus quartal 3
2022 ist übrigens das was wir dieses
jahr auch schon sehr häufig gemacht
haben wir haben unsere impfkampagne im
frühjahr und im sommer viel tempo geben
können weil wir viele bestellungen aus
quartal 4 etwa des herstellers biontech
vorgezogen haben in die quartale zwei
und drei in absprache mit der für die
ganze eu ja nicht nur für deutschland
für die ganze europäische union in
absprache mit dem hersteller war das
möglich und das war sehr hilfreich weil
wir dadurch eben unser versprechen jedem
bis zum ende des sommers die möglichkeit
zu geben sich zu schützen durch eine
impfung tatsächlich am anfang das sollen
wir schon erreicht haben also dass wir
lieferungen vorziehen
insbesondere eben in zeiten wo wir sie
auch dringend brauchen aus gesamt
bestellen mengen die wir haben das ist
regelmäßiges tun dass wir innerhalb der
europäischen union zwischen den ländern
die lieferungen auch ausgleichen je
nachdem wer gerade bedarf hat es
übrigens auch
weil ich das heute medial gelegentlich
sah normales tun wir haben nicht selten
in den letzten monaten auf lieferungen
zu gunsten von anderen eine zeit lang
verzichtet als die sie dringend brauchen
und wir nicht so machen das andere dann
zugunsten von uns in dieser zeit
insofern ist das sozusagen innerhalb der
europäischen union ein normales vorgehen
um die großen mengen die wir gemeinsam
gesichert haben für 20 22 und 23 über
zwei milliarden dosen für die
europäische union auch und den zeitpunkt
zu verfügbar zu haben in denen wir sie
brauchen die mengen liefermengen für
quartal 1 beeinträchtigt das nicht
nachfrage sie haben vorhin in bezug auf
die beschlüsse der ministerpräsidenten
kanzlerin kontrolle schon gestern gesagt
ihr müsst nun energisch durchgesetzt
werden wo sehen sie ihren persönlichen
anteil daran dass diese sagen wir
relativ tief greifenden beschlüsse doch
erst so spät erfolgt sind man hätte sie
haben das auch angedeutet manche ist
früher nicht nur tun können sondern tun
müssen wir als bundesgesundheitsminister
waren und sind da an einer
schlüsselstelle der vorbereitung von
entscheidungen wo haben sie sozusagen
war ich ihn auch mal nicht richtig
gestellt
was die beschlüsse an geht jetzt zur
kontakt einschränkungen und
beschränkungen wie sie zwischen bund und
ländern auf der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
getroffen wurden haben wir hier
gemeinsam in den letzten wochen mehrfach
darauf hingewiesen dass wir sie für
dringlich halten ich habe vor vor vor
letzte woche gesagt es ist fünf nach
zwölf der woche darauf habe ich gesagt
das ist zehn nach zwölf in der woche
darauf habe ich gesagt es ist halb eins
mindestens das ist dringlich dass
beschlüsse zur kontakt beschränkungen
getroffen werden beschlüsse zu kontakt
beschränkung konkret in der umsetzung
kann ich als bundesminister für
gesundheit nicht treffen sondern nach
der geltenden rechtslage können das nur
die länder und die behörden vor ort und
es ist gut dass bei uns darauf gestern
vereinbart hat
digitale frage dazu weil sie inhaltlich
gut passt der kollegin wie der kollege
wegner von dpa afx aktien bieler bis
wann könnten die gestern beschlossenen
maßnahmen auf eine substanzielle
verminderung desinfektions
geschehens wann können sie dazu führen
vorausgesetzt sie werden auch konsequent
umgesetzt
ja also zunächst mal möchte ich auch
noch mal sagen
wir werden eben nur dann zu etwas führen
wenn sie konsequent umgesetzt findet man
das muss man einfach mal klar sagen in
den letzten monaten sind eben nicht alle
beschlüsse konsequent umgesetzt und das
muss man einfach sagen und wenn jemand
dann zum beispiel die wirksamkeit von
maßnahmen bewertet aber gar nicht die
maßnahme implementiert wurde ist
natürlich schwierig also die maßnahme
sind erstmal wichtig und extrem richtig
und wichtig wir werden in etwa zwei
wochen etwas sehen das wissen wir
inzwischen aber auch glaube ich wir
sehen etwa in zwei wochen
dass man dann der anteile
menschen nicht mehr steigt der anteil
derjenigen die im ins krankenhaus
eingeliefert wenn er sehe nur etwa nach
10 bis 14 tagen zwei wochen wir sehen
dass bei den todesfällen in der von 2 3
bis 4 wochen etwa so lange dauert das
also dass aber das ist ja da hat sich ja
auch nicht viel dran geändert in den
letzten zwei jahren das heißt also man
sieht ja jetzt schon es gibt zumindest
hinweise in den ländern wo jetzt stärker
maßnahmen gemacht wurden in bayern oder
sachsen da sieht man ja auch schon
gewisse effekte zumindest gehen wir
davon aus dass so ist also es wird hat
man zeit noch dauern ich kann nur
folgendes sagen und das ist dann würde
ja auch
nicht dass ich mich aufregen wenn dann
die zahlen wieder runter gehen und wenn
dann die maßnahmen wieder gelockert
werden dann werden sie wieder steigen ja
nur das schon mal vorweg gesagt da muss
man auch keine großen zukunftsprognosen
machen also das muss man da wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass diese instanzen sinken
auf dauer weil wir sonst einfach viele
menschen nicht schützen können wir
können bei hohen incidents nicht jeden
jeden schützen koinzidenz sind für den
impfschutz schlecht hohe instanzen sind
für die gesundheit von menschen schlecht
die die chance dass man menschen schützt
bei rollins tänzen ist deutlich geringer
als bei geringen inzidenz über
pflegeheime sprachen es gibt teilweise
pflegeheime dort sind die bewohner oder
die die die angehörigen die mitarbeiter
zu fast 100 prozent geimpft es gibt aber
leider auch immer noch pflegeheim da
weiß ich dass zum beispiel die
angestellten für die hälfte geimpft ist
die kann man dann überhaupt nicht mehr
schützen also das heißt diese maßnahmen
ist nicht wirklich implementiert werden
sie müssen auch dann längere zeit halten
damit war wirklich dauerhaft runter
gehen weil er der winter erst angefangen
mit der kollegin in der mitte rechts für
ihn aus linker pleite ihren namen nicht
parat
angelika slavik und westdeutschen
zeitung wenn sie zurückschauen auf die
letzten zwei jahre haben sie öfter schon
gesagt es gab fehler und sagen wir
besser gelaufen sind in sachen
schlechter gelaufen sind wenn sie jetzt
eine einzige sache ändern könnten eine
sache die sie korrigieren würden damit
wir in einer besseren lage werden was
wir das
wissen sie eine erfahrung einfach auch
ist dass das eben nicht alles auf eine
sache oder eine entscheidung oder eine
maßnahme zurückzuführen ist sondern ich
kann immer wieder nur dafür werben diese
pandemie auch als das zu nehmen was es
ist eine ziemlich komplexe
herausforderung wo es nicht die eine
maßnahme die eine entscheidung das eine
tun gibt das den entscheidenden
unterschied macht wo wir aber eben sehen
und das ist eben die als ich höre häufig
man müsste doch auch drei oder sechs
oder neun monate eine strategie haben
oder länger es ist teil der strategie
immer wieder sich an die dynamische lage
anzupassen das ist sozusagen ein
entscheidender teil der strategie nicht
einfach zu sagen das ist für die
nächsten sechs monate fix und da
passiert nichts sondern sich an die lage
aber dann auch schnell anzupassen und
das ist ja das was wir gerade
nochmal erörtert haben wir sind inland
zu häufig jedenfalls in der anpassung an
die lage nicht schnell genug wenn wir
dann uns einig sind zwischen bund und
ländern an die lage uns anzupassen dann
geschieht das ja auch zügig wenn die
entscheidung getroffen ist von kraftvoll
was wenn sie auch einem konkreten punkt
fragen der aus meiner sicht
wahrscheinlichen entscheidenden
unterschied hätte auch mitmachen können
aber nie für sich allein sondern es ist
immer eine gesamtbetrachtung ist dass
das was ich eingangs meinte mit wir
hätten mit größerer konsequenz diesen
unterschied zwischen geimpft wird uns
schon früher machen müssen im rückblick
es kam eben vor allem die situation
ja dazu dass wir gesehen haben das mit
etwa 12 millionen
ungeimpften erwachsenen wird noch mal in
eine solch schwierige lage kommen können
und als die 2g diskutiert haben bereits
im august auch ich diskutiert habe dafür
geworben habe
da ja wir hätten damals meiner sicht
klarer diesen unterschied schon machen
müssen zwischen games nicht geimpften
war es aber auch das ist nicht nur der
politische frage ist auch eine frage von
gesellschaftlicher akzeptanz dann von
solchen entscheidungen
und mein eindruck ist die war im august
auch noch anders als wir heute ist
sollte aber nicht von entscheidung
abhalten
nachfrage an beide wenn ich darf sie
sitzen ja heute hier wahrscheinlich zum
letzten mal zusammen
normalerweise sehr sparsam mit einem
einblick in ihre gefühlswelt aber
vielleicht kann sie sagen werden sie
einander denn vermissen füreinander
vermissen werden
also ich werde wenn ich darf
abschließend noch was noch was sagen
aber ich kann grundsätzlich sagen dass
natürlich die zusammenarbeit mit herrn
professor wähler mit dem robert koch
institut aber auch mit mit allen
kolleginnen und kollegen im ministerium
und bei uns im geschäftsbereich
vermissen werde weil ich das einfach
auch gerne macht was ich mache
als bundesminister für gesundheit vor
der pandemie mit vielen entscheidungen
und unterschieden die wir haben machen
können im alltag für viele menschen für
patientinnen und patienten für die die
im gesundheitswesen arbeiten und auch in
dieser pandemie durch entscheidung einen
unterschied machen zu können mitgeholfen
zu haben dieses land durch die pandemie
zu führen dass das ist etwas was in
meinem politischen verständnis
entspricht deswegen ich mal angefangen
hat politik zu machen das geht nur dann
bin ich wieder bei ihrer frage in einem
team und das gilt nur in guter
zusammenarbeit im ministerium mit allen
die ihm auch in den unterschiedlichen
stellen verantwortung haben wie das ist
in einer stressreichen zeit wie den
letzten 18 monaten natürlich haben wir
auch manches mal miteinander diskutiert
das gehört aber auch dazu aber wir haben
am ende immer ich finde jedenfalls auch
in konkreten dinge ich manchmal auch um
ganz konkrete fragen dann von ressourcen
und anderen dingen wir haben immer eine
lösung gefunden und dafür bin ich
einfach dankbar
weiß ich nicht wenn wir dann sehen
das wird man wohl zuerst was man
vermisst wenn wir uns nicht mehr hat
eine frage die gitarre von der kollegin
sowie tief von watson
ersparen wieso sind fußballspiele
weiterhin mit 15.000 zuschauern erlaubt
das ist ja teil der bundesländer
beschlossen gestern die im stadion
singen grölen und sich auf dem weg
dorthin in falun es im fall s-bahn
quetschen wie kann diese entscheidung
anderen also gegenüber anderen branchen
erklärt und gerechtfertigt werden es ist
eine frage um die tatsächlich ja auch
gerungen und diskutiert wurde im vorfeld
aber auch in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
kompromiss ist es jetzt zu dieser
größenordnung gekommen ist ist ja schon
eine deutliche reduktion wenn das
umgesetzt wird mit 2g regeln masken
idealerweise ohne alkohol und
idealerweise mit anfahrts und abfahrts
konzepten die eben keine großen
menschenansammlungen beinhalten dann ist
das sicherlich auch
in der theorie jedenfalls eine gute
sache die frage ist ob das in der praxis
gelingt das mit all diesen regeln
umzusetzen wir alle kennen die bilder
aus stadien wo das nicht immer wirklich
den eindruck macht dass das überall
gelingt und deswegen verstehe ich gut
dass da vor allem auch im vergleich mit
anderen bereichen
dass da viele fragen dazu sind ich kann
jetzt nur dafür werben dass dieser
gefundene kompromiss auch wirklich in
all seinen facetten
zweig masken aha regeln an und abfalls
konzepte auch umgesetzt wird
ein bisschen lauter wie schätzen sie
denn im beitrag verlauf der panini ist
wahrscheinlich schwierig aber bei seiner
vierten welle womit rechnen sie
gesagt eine frage und eine nachfrage ich
habe es versucht
also
das ist wirklich nicht leicht zu
beantworten die frage welt dieser
verlauf der welle hängt jetzt davon ab
was jetzt getan wird also das eine ist
was in unserem land konkret getan wird
ich sagte es wenn die maßnahmen die
gestern beschlossen werden wenn die
wirklich umfänglich implementiert werden
dann wird die vierte welle schneller
vorbei gehen und weniger auch todesopfer
haben als wenn sie nicht vernünftig
implementiert wird das heißt also
reduktion von kontakten um infektionen
zu vermeiden und gleichzeitig viel
impfen um schwere krankheitsverläufe
todesfälle zu vermeiden es hängt also
ganz davon ab wie das umgesetzt wird und
je mehr menschen nach dieser vierten
welle eine immunität haben werden desto
geringer wird eine fünfte welle eine
mögliche fünfte welle aber ich da ich
nicht weiß ich weiß weder was die
ministerpräsidenten vielleicht in zwei
wochen entscheiden noch weiß ich wie
alle menschen sich verhalten werden also
ich bin eigentlich optimistisch dass
oder dann mal so ich weiß ja dass der
große mehrheit der leute die in unserem
land leben verstanden haben dass das
jetzt eine echte notsituation ist eine
krisensituation dass man jetzt
zusammenstehen muss und dass man das
gemeinsam lösen muss insofern bin ich
optimistisch dass die vierte welle
kleiner wird aber ich kann sie nicht
nicht sagen ja ich kann noch nicht mal
sagen wie viele menschen geimpft werden
werden sein werden wir haben genügend
impfstoff da aber wie viele menschen an
diesem stoff nehmen weiß ich ja auch
nicht und wir können gern modulieren
oder oder prognostizieren aber wir
wissen es nicht ich hoffe dass die
impfraten weiter steigen ich bin sehr
optimistisch dass sie das tun weil sie
seit wirklich tagen endlich wieder
steigen und wenn wir alle zusammen
dadurch gehen dann wird die virtuelle
deutlich angenehmer verlaufen als wenn
man das nicht tun also zuerst einmal zum
vierten welle dünnschicht uns wünsche
ich dem land einfach das mit dem was
gestern beschlossen worden ist mit dem
was im alltag viele bürgerinnen und
bürger leben ist gelingt diese welle zu
brechen die zahlen nach unten zu bringen
vor allem eben diejenigen die jeden tag
enormes leisten und leisten müssen in
den krankenhäusern auch deutlich zu
entlasten leid zu vermeiden die frage
wie es dann nach einer
vierten welle weitergeht
hängt natürlich von vielen facetten ab
ist nur eins ja irgendwie für uns
kollektiv als gesellschaft und nicht nur
in deutschland sondern wenn ich auf die
welt schaue habe ich den eindruck ist es
jetzt nicht nur deutschland ist gerade
mit dieser lage kämpft also nicht nur
mit der welle sondern auch mit viel wut
frust weil man irgendwie dachte mein
held das schlimmste hinter sich
und dann kam es doch ganz anders
und das ist vielleicht einmal mehr
einfach auch eine lehre für das was noch
kommen kann dass wir uns freuen wenn es
gelingt sie zu brechen dass wir uns
freuen wenn es gelingt mehr menschen zur
impfung zu überzeugen
dass wir aber eben weiterhin auch
aufpassen was varianten angeht was die
frage angeht was auch in einer möglichen
fünften welle passieren kann
ich vermag das nicht vorherzusagen dafür
ist einfach in diesen letzten 18 monaten
zu oft so viel
unvorhergesehenes
oder oder etwas was noch möglichkeit war
ich meine wenn einige immer sagen haben
wir doch immer gewusst es war eine
möglichkeit dass es nicht so entwickelt
es gab aber auch die möglichkeit dass es
sich anders entwickelt das war ja immer
eine frage wie geht's weiter so oder so
rum
und das vermag ich abschließend nicht
vorherzusagen für das nächste jahr ich
wünsche jedenfalls uns in diesem land
dass wir jetzt erstmal mit dem was
entschieden ist und dem was wir tun
diese welle brechen
frage
welche rolle werden denn als auch was
die zukunft betrifft medikamente spielen
also die usa und großbritannien setzen
na ja sehr auf medikamente und es macht
auch diejenigen zu entlasten also vor
augen wie ist die situation in
deutschland ich wäre wohl die frage kurz
weil dessen sind in den vortagen sehr
schwer zu hören ist die frage war nach
medikamenten und deren bedeutung im
weiteren verlauf also mit 19 medikamente
therapeutika spielen eine große rolle
sollen und müssen sie auch spielen
deswegen haben wir ja auch mehrere
programme der forschungsförderung des
bundes auch für die entwicklung
entsprechender medikamente von
vielversprechenden ansätzen und wir
haben und sind auch gerade aktuell noch
dabei bis zur letzten sekunde aktiv
sozusagen
auch mit herstellern entsprechende
verträge zu verhandeln die
aussichtsreiche medikamente haben dabei
ist eines wichtig weil sie sind jetzt
das spannende ist ja die ganze die ganze
spannbreite habe ich heute auch wieder
in der öffentlichen aufbereitung gesehen
wo die einen sagen warum haben die
eigentlich im november 2020 für viel
geld monoklonale antikörper bestellt
heute wie konnten die für so viel geld
bestellen einen teil der
berichterstattung ein teil an anderer
stelle der berichterstattung war warum
greifen die nicht viel großzügiger zu
bei therapeutischer die vielversprechend
sind dann muss man doch einfach erst mal
bestellen und dann gucken so das ist ja
nur die ganze spannbreite sozusagen der
debatte ich finde wir sind mit unserem
ansatz
dort wo es auch auf solide datenbasis
mein wir haben medikamente gehabt die
wurden gehabt zwei drei tage lang nach
dem motto muss jetzt jeder nehmen die
haben sich dann wenige wochen und monate
später leider muss man ja dann sagen als
nicht wirklich hilfreich teilweise sogar
eher schwierig herausgestellt als die
studienlage da war aber immer dann wenn
wir auch nach den einschätzungen unserer
behörden des bvb des
paul-ehrlich-instituts je nachdem um
welche art von medikament es geht einen
aussichtsreichen kandidaten haben auch
nach studienlage 1 unterschied zu machen
haben wir verhandlungen begonnen mit dem
hersteller so haben wir uns mdc wir
gesichert für deutschland so haben wir
monoklonale antikörper gesichert für
deutschland so haben wir ganz aktuell
mit msd in verhandlungen das dortige
medikament für deutschland gesichert in
einer ersten vertrag 80.000 dosen
natürlich reden wir auch über folge
verträge aber es war mir erst mal
wichtig dass wir erste lieferungen noch
im dezember haben so sind wir in
verhandlungen aktuell auch mit pfizer
und mit anderen über über deren
medikamente und haben dann immer auch
auf basis von nationalen sonder
zulassung wenn ich das mal um technisch
so nennen darf ist ja dann möglich
gemacht sie auch einzusetzen
und wenn ich eins hinzufügen darf das
sind am ende natürlich auch dinge
die dann es erfordern auch das ganze
gewicht der bundesrepublik deutschland
einzubringen
also medikament wie das von msd und
pfizer da ist mindestens mal
sich länder gerade natürlich die dass
auch bestellen und fordern wollen und
das sind dann dinge wie es auch
transparent zu machen wo auch ja der
minister selbst mit den
vorstandsvorsitzenden dieser unternehmen
spricht und verhandeln muss in teilen um
den weg dafür zu bauen das lässt sich
anders bei einem weltweit und kämpften
produkt dann auch nicht regeln aber die
grund antwort ist ja wir haben hohes
interesse an therapeutischer bei coop 19
wir kaufen vorsorglich wir unterstützen
forschung und entwicklung weil selbst
bei höchsten impfquoten ist immer auch
diejenigen gibt wo möglicherweise auch
beim ems durchbruch behandlungsbedarf
entsteht der kollegin von ihnen gesehen
von ihnen aus gesehen links
ich habe eine falsche anzeige und zwar
der chef der eu kommission ab gesagt
dass er sein fehlen dann nicht ihn zu
lassen wurde also was halten sie davon
und zwar
nicht nur von merkels und andere von
anderen biologisch über die eventuelle
nebenwirkungen in der lange zeit weil
die studie sind nicht nach und die
diesen maximen es ist auch ganz neu
also was halten sie davon
also zuerst einmal die ständige
impfkommission genießt hohes ansehen ich
bin ja auch dankbar für ihre arbeit aber
ich denke es ist eben auch wichtig dass
dann empfehlungen die zu machen sind
dann auch als empfehlung auf
wissenschaftlicher basis gemacht werden
nicht bevor überhaupt begonnen worden
ist daten auszuwerten
gerade kinder impfungen sind sehr
sensible eine sehr sensible frage eine
frage die viele eltern beschäftigte und
ihre und ihre kinder deswegen kann ich
einfach nur dazu auffordern dass alle
die mit den entscheidungen der
öffentlichen debatte aus berufenem munde
sozusagen betroffen sind dass das eben
auch mit dieser entsprechenden
zurückhaltung und grundhaltung machen
dass das für diejenigen die die
informationen dann bekommen die diese
aussagen sehen daneben schon auch eine
sd zurecht und nachvollziehbar eben auch
mit einem abwägen und mit emotionen
verbunden ist ich kann nur eins sagen
und ich finde der professor sander hat
er auch die richtigen entscheidungen der
richtigen worte gefunden der
impfentscheidung hat er sinngemäß gesagt
muss gut abgewogen sein aber es geht
nicht um die entscheidung für oder gegen
die impfung es geht um die entscheidung
ob infektionen mit schutz oder runde
schutz das ist die entscheidung um die
es geht auch für die impfung von kindern
und wir erleben in den zuschriften die
wir bekommen dass viele eltern sich sehr
hoffen erwarten erwünschen zum schutz
ihrer kinder dass es einen
entsprechenden impfstoff gibt es gibt ja
sogar auch da wo es vor erkrankte kinder
gibt teilweise aus sorge wegen der
vorerkrankung im einzelfall den off
label use der berichtet wird also das
vorhandene impfstoffe schon genutzt
werden und umso wichtiger ist es dass
endlich auch eben wir diesen
zugelassenen impfstoff verfügbar haben
dann auch mit der ordentlichen zulassung
wir als und die ordentliche zulassung
ist eine durch eine zulassungsbehörde
und wir werden mit dieser zulassung und
der verfügbarkeit des impfstoffes den
fünf- bis elfjährigen die impfung in der
entscheidung ihrer eltern und des arztes
auch möglich machen und dann wird die
ständige impfkommission eine empfehlung
abgeben ich will aber empfehlen
empfehlungen als abzugeben und nicht als
persönliche meinung
bin sehr sicher oder mein eindruck ist
das war ja in einem podcast in
gesprochene aber das müssen sie am
besten im professor mehr uns selbst
fragen dass die formulierung so wie sie
auch verstanden werden konnte zu den
langzeitfolgen nicht das ist was
intendiert war
alles andere würde mich verwundert
also ich möchte noch mal kurz sagen die
stiko macht eine hervorragende arbeit
die stiko hat eine bestimmte sp eine
sogenannte standard operating procedure
nach der viele länder sich sehnen würden
dass sie so etwas hätten die stiko
besteht aus 18 mitgliedern die sind
ehrenamtlich sind alles hervorragende
fachleute auf ihren gebieten und die
entscheiden nach auf basis von
wissenschaftlichen daten und das werden
sie auch dieses mal tun und dann steht
in der begründung dieser entscheidung
stehen alle diese dinge die sie
ansprechen drin die sind ja alle teil
der begründung und ich würde sie einfach
immer bitten wenn diese stücke
entscheidung dann kommen die sind ja
wirklich umfangreich begründet lesen sie
hier und dann sind alle diese aspekte
mit
beachtet worden und ich kann nur sagen
die stiko macht das jetzt in dieser
arbeitsbelastung ja nun seit über einem
jahr und ich bin dann mit ihren der
stiko und allen die die stiko
unterstützen auch die geschäftsstelle am
robert-koch-institut mehr als nur
dankbar für das was sie leisten und es
ist eben wissenschaftlich basiert und
basiert eben nicht auf einzelne
meinungen sondern auch
wissenschaftlichen daten und das wird
auch so bleiben
der kollege holstein von apotheke adhoc
fragt digitalen sie gericht ersparen
wollen haben sie verschwiegen dass die
booster kampagne ohne zusätzliche vorab
lieferung der hersteller aus dem jahr
2022 in gefahr geraten könnten bei 64
millionen dosen moderner plötzlich
gespendet werden
also ich weiß nicht ob er holstein die
gelegenheit hatte den letzten
pressekonferenzen hierzu folgen am
freitag aber die größenordnung der an
kovacs gespendeten dosen war hier
gefühlt fast jede woche thema insofern
ist da nichts verschwiegen worden im
übrigen stand sie auch auf unserer
homepage es gibt kabinettsbeschlüsse
dazu sind übrigens keine entscheidung
des bundesministeriums für gesundheit
sondern die frage was in welchem umfang
gespendet wird an drittländer sind
gemeinsame entscheidungen natürlich des
auswärtigen amtes des bmz des
finanzministeriums das kanzleramt des
und des gesundheitsministeriums weil es
ja verschiedene aspekte dabei zu
berücksichtigen wird und gleichzeitig
ist einfach die schlussfolgerung ja
nicht richtig wir können gerade beides
leisten können genug impfstoff für die
impfkampagne in deutschland zur
verfügung stellen mehr als genug
und wir können helfen die welt zu impfen
und ich finde wenn irgendwas gezeigt hat
dass das sinn macht dann doch die letzte
woche omikron
varianten können dann entstehen wenn es
in regionen auf der welt eben
entsprechende infektionen und instanzen
gibt sie können überall auf der welt
entstehen dessen macht es viel sinn die
welt zu impfen und deswegen haben wir
immer auch aus eigenem nationalen
interesse
mitgeholfen finanziell und durch die
spende von impfdosen
dass die welt geimpft werden kann wir
haben gleichzeitig die möglichkeit die
deutsche bevölkerung zu impfen zur frage
um das auch ausgesprochen zu haben
moderner dosen kovacs gibt es übrigens
gerade eine herausfordernde situation
für kovacs
dass sie nämlich nicht schnell genug
genug abnehmer finden für alle von der
eu ländern gespendeten dosen wir haben
gerade die situation dass man auf der
suche ist nach einem zentrallager in der
eu für gespendete dosen
weil man nicht schnell genug drittländer
findet die sie aufnehmen und umsetzen
können weil es ja auch die strukturen
dafür braucht das dann zu tun
so und damit dann diese dosen zu einem
sinnvollen einsatz kommen finde ich
machte es dann auch sinn dass die eu mit
den staaten die ja alle gerade booster
kampagnen haben
oder eben über noch einmal verstärkte
impfkampagnen bis hin zu impfpflicht
teilweise diskutieren dann auch schauen
ob man auch da dosen mit zum einsatz
bringen kann das reduziert nicht die
gesamtmenge der gespendeten dosen aber
auch da ist das ein ständiges im
ausgleich bringen zwischen dem was
überhaupt abschließend abgerufen wird
und dem was dann auch entsprechend zur
verfügung gestellt wird sagt noch einmal
also transparenter als die frage das wir
kovacs unterstützen und in deutschland
gut impfen haben wir wir haben alle
themen transparent behandelt aber das
haben wir besonders transparent
behandelt miteinander
zwei letzte fragen im saal der kollege
von ihnen aus gesehen rechts hinten dann
ist die warnung
daniel n tv herr wiener portugal hat mit
78 prozent einer der höchsten in der
welt und denke das land jetzt nochmal
den im notfall zustand können sie sich
das erklären oder heißt das dass eine
gesellschaft trotz vor impfquote nicht
sicher ist vor verschärften kohler
massen haben also zunächst einmal
muss man immer im kopf haben dass es
eben auch natürlich in portugal ein im
juni gibt also diese beobachtung die wir
machen dass der impfschutz nach einer
gewissen zeit das ist ein aspekt den wir
immer im kopf haben müssen und den wir
natürlich immer besser kennen lernen das
heißt also dann geht es darum dass man
den impfschutz entsprechende auffrischt
das andere was wir immer im kopf haben
müssen das ist das zurzeit natürlich
nach wie vor eine pandemie unterwegs ist
und und didi ist normal weltweit und das
heißt also wir müssen immer im kopf
haben das ist ein baukasten von
verschiedenen maßnahmen ist wie wir
parallel fahren müssten gewisse zeit
also darum ist es auch wichtig für sie
zu verstehen es gibt nicht diese eine
maßnahme mit der wir alles lösen sondern
wir haben ein set von medikamenten wir
haben bestimmte schutzmaßnahmen also
infektionsschutz maßnahmen und eben die
impfung und
87 prozentigen quote ist super aber die
reicht natürlich auch nicht aus im
winter wir wissen das ja also ich kann
nur noch mal an die modellierung des rk
erinnern wir brauchen
in schutz er so hoch geht wir irgend
möglich und wir werden sicher diese
pandemie wirklich nicht beenden bevor
nicht jeder ein immunschutz hat und ich
kann immer nur noch mal ganz klar sagen
lieber hole ich mir den immunschutz
durch eine impfung als durch eine
natürliche infektion und das heißt also
wir dürfen halt die nächsten monate
nicht nachlassen wir müssen immer noch
gewisse vorsichtsmaßnahmen walten lassen
damit es eben nicht zu schnell hoch geht
aber das entscheidend ist wenn man sieht
dass die zahlen wieder nach oben gehen
dann muss man eben maßnahmen einbringen
um das unten zu halten ich kann immer
nur in unseren plan kontrollen co wird
erinnern je früher man interveniert
desto desto stärker sind die
auswirkungen der interventionen desto
weniger fälle werden im auftreten das
heißt also dieses spiel diese
wachsamkeit das wird uns noch einige
monate immer wieder im
bewegen und darum ist sie dann ein
baukasten den wir immer wieder neu
taxieren müssen das total wichtig also
nicht auf eine sache nur verlassen das
hat diese pandemie zum einen allen ja
gezeigt aber auch alle die menschen die
die sich wirklich gut mit solchen viren
und epidemiologie auskennen natürlich
dass es bevor wirklich eine gute bonität
da ist ein pandemie einfach nicht zu
ende kommt das haben wir auch schon vor
100 jahren gesehen da haben wir nicht so
genau gesehen würde einfach nicht so gut
hin gucken konnten aber so ist das nun
nicht nur eins hinzufügen darf
weil sich portugal ansprachen wir sehen
zwei jahre in spanien frankreich
dänemark
länder die tatsächlich aber impfquoten
noch haben als wir und die entwicklung
in diesen ländern zeigt dem es ist es
ist nicht monokausal
und wir sind in einer besonders
schwierigen situation in dieser vierten
welle aktuell aber wir sind tatsächlich
wenn sie die gesamtschau nehmen
insgesamt in der europäischen union in
dieser vierten welle scheint auch so wie
ich das waren immer der erste kontinent
zu sein denn dieser werde so in dieser
wucht trifft okay der einzige bleiben
werden wir ja auch in den nächsten
monaten dann sehen ich wünsche es der
welt dass das möglichst in anderen
regionen nicht so kommt aber es zeigt
eben das ist immer die suche nach der
einen entscheidung dem ein parameter das
eine was den unterschied gemacht hätte
oder nicht und gerade der blick in
andere länder zeigt eben dass eine
alleine hätte den entscheid unterschied
auch nicht gemacht aber es hätte schon
einen wichtigen unterschied gemacht
jetzt
sparen doch mal eine frage zu ihrer
persönlichen bilanz ich könnte noch mal
sagen als minister
entscheidung hat sie stolz gemacht
selber und möglicherweise welche eigene
entscheidung über die sie sich
nachdenklich vielleicht geärgert haben
und wie geht es mit der tatsache dass
sie jetzt das aus dem amt scheiden was
sicherlich sehr anspruchsvoll und mit
hoher taktrate versehen war mit vielen
entscheidungen
die jetzt
also ob sie jetzt glauben wir dann nicht
abschließend so richtig gedanken habe
ich mir dazu allerdings noch nicht
gemacht ich glaube dass auch jetzt auch
einfach noch ein bisschen den abstand
und rückschau
zu diesen fragen und diesen punkten ich
mache jetzt wirklich bis zur letzten
sekunde bis zur amtsübergabe meine
aufgabe als bundesminister für
gesundheit das halte ich jedenfalls in
der lage in der aktuell sind auch für
erforderlich und das ist das was mich
treibt und beschäftigt
ich habe schon gesagt warum ich auch was
mein politikverständnis ist dass ich das
gerne mache was ich tue und ich hätte
ohne zweifel auch gerne weitergemacht
aber dass andersen setzte messi meint es
ist jetzt eine entscheidung zum
regierungswechsel
unternehmen bedeutet das auch ein
wechsel gibt
und sie ist mir dabei geht das jetzt
auch gar nicht so wichtig und so schauen
wir dann mal dann in der folge ich
jedenfalls merck in meinem alltag stone
noch nicht den anstehenden wechsel
sondern bemerke ich wahrscheinlich erst
so richtig ab
wahrscheinlich wenn ich es richtig weiß
nächsten mittwoch
damit sind wir zumindest am ende der
fragerunde angekommen und nachdem das
die letzte pressekonferenz in dieser
konstellation mit dem noch
geschäftsführenden bundesminister der
gesundheit war gebe ich noch mal das
wort ersparen er liebe frau wolff meine
damen und herren dies tatsächlich ja
meine letzte bundespressekonferenz als
bundesminister für gesundheit ist möchte
ich noch einfach ein paar allgemeine
anmerkung machen wir haben uns hier seid
pandemie beginn etwa 50 mal in dieser
bundespressekonferenz getroffen
deshalb möchte ich mich zum ersten
bedanken bei den vielen expertinnen und
experten die in diesem rahmen für
sachliche gute informationen gesorgt
haben die auch mit uns hier regelmäßig
in der bundespressekonferenz waren wir
können uns glücklich schätzen in
deutschland ich würde mir wünschen dass
wir auch das gelegentlich wahrnehmen
dass das ein privileg ist dass wir so
viele expertinnen und experten haben
universitäten wissenschaftler aber auch
in der medizinischen versorgung im
alltag die in dieser pandemie uns mit
rat und tat begleiten und unterstützen
ich habe versucht meinen beitrag zu
leisten dass dieser expertinnen und
experten hier auch zu wort kommen können
in der öffentlichen debatte
einen besonderen dank möchte ich ein
professor wieder
aussprechen sie haben sich hier immer
wieder den fragen gestellt die lage
beschrieben und gesagt was notwendig ist
sie haben zeitweise auch viel abbekommen
in der öffentlichkeit in der
öffentlichen debatte aber sie haben nie
den kopf eingezogen ich war und bin
dankbar sie hier an meiner seite zu
wissen und ich glaube auch viele
bürgerinnen und bürger rechnen ihnen das
hoch an
und nicht zuletzt möchte ich mich bei
dem verein der bundespressekonferenz und
bei den journalistinnen und journalisten
bei ihnen bedanken sie haben es uns
ermöglicht die bürgerinnen und bürger
direkt über aktuelle entwicklungen zu
informieren
sie haben kritisch nachgefragt das ist
richtig und wichtig und gleichzeitig
habe ich hier das miteinander immer auch
als fair empfunden auch dafür bin ich
dankbar kleider die zahlreichen versuche
mit desinformation in unserem land
gerade in dieser schwierigen phase für
misstrauen und wut zu sorgen zeigen wie
wichtig ein unabhängiger und kritischer
fakten geleiteter journalismus ist sie
haben diese verantwortung wahrgenommen
ich bitte sie nehmen sie sie weiter war
vor allem bleiben sie gesund
vielen dank für diese guten wünsche
ersparen lassen sie mich im namen dieses
vereins an und des vorstands am diesen
dank noch erwidern vielen dank dass auch
sie regelmäßig hier waren sich den
fragen gestellt die informationen nach
außen getragen haben sich dieser
öffentlichkeit gestellt haben dieser
dank gilt natürlich auch an herrn wieder
bei ihm hoffen wir auf ein baldiges
wiedersehen bei ihnen zumindest in
dieser funktion
vermutlich nicht
sie sind unsere unser büro führt ja eine
sehr gute dokumentation sie sind ja als
rekordhalter und waren allein 20 21 31
mal hier insgesamt in ihre amtszeit wenn
das richtig gezählt es 58 mal damit mit
dieser gesamtzahlen sie nicht ganz
rekordhalter aber sie bewegen sich in
sehr illustre runde öfter war nur sigmar
gabriel wolfgang schäuble und thomas de
maizière in ihrer jeweiligen amtszeit
hier
vielen dank es wäre natürlich schöner
gewesen wenn ihr kommen an dieser stelle
unter besseren bedingungen stattfinden
hätte können wenn es nicht unter
pandemischen bedingungen ist dennoch
vielen dank alles gute und einen schönen
tag in einer dankeschön
[Musik]